it's great to welcome to the program
today Mike Gravel who is a former US
senator serving from 1969 to 1981 he's
not only a former presidential candidate
but is now a 2020 Democratic
presidential contender senator Gravelle
really a pleasure having you on let's
just jump into it why why are you
running why have you added your name to
the long list of candidates running well
because young man 17 years old and his
partner Henry Williams it was David Oaks
who contacted me and asked me if I would
run for president and I said do you have
any idea how old I am and he said well
that doesn't matter what counts is your
position on the issues and they had
shown me the research that they did on
my background and also on Tulsi Gabbard
and they just felt that that the issues
that I had to present should be
presented to the American public in a
course of the presidential election the
way to do that of course is to be able
to get them in the debates and so they
took on the task of trying to get sixty
five thousand dollars
they've got presently around a 1/3 or
almost pushing towards a half of the
donors and they've got over 60 70
thousand dollars that they've raised and
they came out to visit me about a month
ago David couldn't come because he got
hospitalized just before his flight but
a gentleman by neighborhood church and
also Henry Williams came out and we did
some video taping and went over with
David the platform that were ascribing
to and so that's what
into this situation I turned over the
Twitter account that I never used from
the OE
campaign and they've been handling it
very diligently and so I'm not doing any
work it was part of the plan that they
wouldn't have to do any work other than
be interviewed by people like you David
so okay let's start getting into some of
the stuff because the as you mentioned
you've turned over control of the
Twitter account to to these young guys
is it true what I'm reading that
sometimes they post stuff under your
name that you don't even really agree
with I don't know about what I agree
with that we went over great detail they
always asked me before they post
something if I agree with this and I be
I told him show me I agree now there may
be something I did caution them about
being negative on other candidates
because I don't think that's productive
because we're an issue situation and I
wouldn't I don't know of any issues that
they put up that I would disagree with
and and so when it ends if somebody does
see something they think that it's
uncharacteristic of my past and then
they could just let you know and I would
discuss it with they keep what I call
our they grab Elisa's the kids and who
are managing a campaign I am NOT
managing campaign I make myself
available for interviews like this but
that's the extent of it okay so here's
one thing that I would sort of want to
get directly into which is since you
were a senator between 69 and 81 and
2016 right so pre Trump the dynamics and
the sort of tenor and tone in the Senate
and in American politics changed
significantly because that's a long
period of time and of course since the
election of Donald Trump with the advent
of so much policy being communicated on
Twitter by the president and the sort of
language and vocabulary and style that
is now being adopted by more and more
members of the House and Senate how
different is it really from what you see
now compared to the way it was when you
were in the Senate in terms of the way
politics is done or is it superficially
different but still basically working
the same way in your estimation no it's
it's not acting the Republican Party
back then and credibility may not have
greed with them but the the essential
crazy reasonable people that had the
conservative views you have today with
the trumpian and not the Republican
Party but it's a truncated party because
the Republicans have lined up to a man
except probably for Lisa Murkowski and
and and the senator from Maine Susan
Collins but to them it's just it's an
abomination yeah
can you get am I still being recorded or
well you're with us you're with a
senator okay the the sort of situation
today is is much worse because of the
Republican Party which has turned around
and totally capitulated itself to the
will of Donald Trump who essentially is
a narcissistic fool but and so if if he
is that and he's proven himself to be
that then the Republican Party to a man
or a woman is is is behind him totally
and so that that leaves the situation
which i think is very unusual and that
is that if Trump loses the election
which I dearly hope you will he would
drag down the Republican Party with him
and so this could be a really nice
moving situation in 2020 but so it
wasn't that way before not before it was
bad enough they had the divisions
and the the things were done improperly
but more subtly than they are today
here it's it's really over and and
truthfully many times ridiculous what do
you think it would take to get back not
not that things were perfect when you
were in the Senate but there are some
analyses I've seen which showed that
when you were in the Senate the
frequency with which Republicans and
Democrats would work together to get
certain things done was significantly
higher than it is today the the level of
division today is significantly higher
what do you think it would take to get
back in the direction of the period
between 69 and 81 when you when you were
in the Senate to get at least some
working together would it be a national
emergency or calamity of some kind would
it be I mean just what what would it
take well what would it take I don't
think it can be repaired I'm coming out
with a book in this summer which is the
title of it is human governance and the
failure of representative government and
a solution which is the people my
personally believe that that
representative government is has failed
and I don't mean just now it goes back
to the beginning of our Constitution
where slavery was embedded forever
infinity and and the genocide that we
committed against the American Indians
so no our our situation is better
because of scientific advancement not
because of governments advancement and
so the only answer that I can think of
is to empower the people to make laws
and I've spent the last 25 years working
on that particular issue and and have a
constitutional amendment and a federal
law which would be the legislative
procedures because he can't just people
can't just make law without procedures
that's anarchy that's what we see what
breaks it right now what they need to do
is to have a constitutional amendment
that lays out some vital aspects of this
and then a process to enact this into
law no it's it's the people that can
make the change straightaway and and
this will surprise a lot of people
because conventional wisdom is that then
you can only change the government
through article 5 of the Constitution
well that's how the government does but
what about the people are the people
stuck with the structure it's been that
it was that's 300 years old and acts
that way and and you have science which
is going up and making discoveries and
changes and brought human society to a
higher level than it's ever been
but what's holding it back is the
structure of governance which is 300
years old and hasn't even been repaired
at all and that's what I'm hoping
so when you say is there a chance no I
think we're we're stuck we're gonna
continue what's been going on for the
last 300 years which is not admirable oh
we we build it up like you know we're
great we're superior we're City on the
hill no it gives me a break our conduct
today in the world is appalling and and
when you look at the nuclear threat that
we have this is literally a suicide pact
that we have that's been devised within
the Pentagon give you an example we're
spending 1.7 trillion dollars now if you
look at the cost overruns the real money
that's going to be spent is going to be
around 3 trillion dollars so we're
spending these treaties for million
dollars to refurbish our nuclear arsenal
and the purpose of that stated by the
head of the Joint Chiefs and by the
Pentagon is that we want to be able to
strength terror in the hearts of our
opponents so that they will know that we
have the will the will to use these
nuclear devices and of course we're
probably the only country in the world
of the eight nukes nuke
trees were the one that says that we're
prepared to use it as a first strike now
here's the kicker the the ability to use
these nuclear devices is zero if any
country were to use its nuclear
capability to attack another country
don't worry about retaliation they're
gonna trigger a nuclear winter and we're
all gonna die yeah yeah yeah I feel like
that's just missed in many of the
discussions about nuclear proliferation
senator one of the things I wanted to
ask you ask you about because a lot of
your critiques are not just critiques of
the right but there are also critiques
of the Democratic Party what one issue
would you like to see the Democratic
Party in general move on what what issue
would that be what do you think the
Democratic Party is most wrong about
right now well don't what do one issue
that I would be very fond of is
single-payer health care there's no the
Obama care package and I was was really
a subsidy to the insurance industry and
the pharmaceutical industry and and
they've sold it it's it's a great detail
and and so but there's no reason why we
can't have single-payer health care i
availed myself of veterans the VA and
also sometimes medicare that says I have
both but but there's no reason why the
entire American population should have
Medicare and or some equivalent of the
VA and it costs money but then I was
just pointing out to you that we got the
Defense Department that is using up
three to three trillion dollars but we
can pay for Medicare for everybody and
we can wipe out the school debt and we
can get whatever so with the money's
there we don't have to raise taxes and
that's what the Republicans pointed oh
the Democrats are gonna raise taxes you
know how to do that just just
about some some salmon in our defense
posture Robert McNamara secretary of
defense was asked as he was leaving
office how much could we really cut the
federal budget that the defense budget
he said 50 percent well he'll look at if
we did away with the Triad which is with
the nukes we have nukes for the Air
Force Got News for the Navy we got nukes
for the army if we did away with the
Army and Air Force we'd still have
unbelievable security with the twelve
Trident submarines that each any one of
them with 280 warheads could hold the
world hostage so we're in a ridiculous
situation where we're spending like
fools on on a military capability that
is unwarranted I'm not saying that we
don't need some defense posture of
course I don't like I say our summer our
Trident submarines could handle our
defense to a fairly well so we could cut
back on a whole bunch of things close a
lot of bases around the world and begin
to bring some sanity to our budgetary
process and that is to be able to take
care of the health care of the people to
take care of the education of people and
to build back our infrastructure the it
was a recent article by the concerned
scientists that said that what we got to
do is we've got to make our opponents
comfortable and in a emotionally
comfortable because if they think we're
going to attack them then they're going
to react and and that's where you get
into a situation where accidents could
occur in the whole nuclear area and
that's because all of our appointments
are our threats
supposedly and I say supposedly because
I don't think you're a real in this
regard but when you look at what's going
on in the nuclear and in the cyber stage
we're talking about a new kind
of warfare but but we keep handling it
we keep manufacturing all the tools for
the old kind of warfare tanks and
artillery pieces that's not the future
the future is going to be either a
nuclear accident which is going to
destroy the planet or it's going to be a
long-term plan of suicide
with respect to the environment so we
have to begin to handle these questions
and they're improperly handled today so
when you ask me is there any hope with
respect to the Congress here you're not
even going to hear a member running for
president that's going to bring up the
military-industrial complex except Tulsi
Gabbard and she's not getting traction
because mainstream media which is
controlled by the military-industrial
complex is going to try to sideline and
marginalize her well I mean bernice aunt
Bernie Sanders did speak quite a bit
about the military industrial complex in
his in his Fox News town hall last week
I don't know if you saw that I I did see
that and and that's the first time that
he's done that I've noticed and he's
mentioned he's said it very clearly that
he did not do a good job on foreign
policy in his last run and that now he's
spending time getting up to speed on
foreign policy I would hope if he gets
the nomination that he would select
Tulsi Gabbard as his vice president
maybe he will that's that's been
mentioned that that's certainly a
possibility he said he would be
interested in having a woman senator
Gravelle let me pause briefly we are
we've been speaking with a former US
Senator Mike Gravel who is running for
president this is the end of the
interview for the broadcast show but
check out the full interview on YouTube
because we're going to continue talking
to him just a little bit more